Oh what is going on YouTube I've been
getting a lot of comments for people
telling me that they are tired of being
the nice guy but I feel like that's just
be a bad guy because not guys don't get
[ __ ] see and that attitude right there
it's true Murr you felt a little mill
phone this right here this before all
men are all situations but of course we
don't get [ __ ] you don't want because
they believe for some reason that the
bad guy is either one oh he thought I
didn't compete a little nah day or two
he's not a bad guy he's just a
misunderstood so then I can turn this
piece of [ __ ] into a print read listen
ladies y'all want help I'm fixing this
situation well I'm here to help you out
LG let's get it let's go well maybe I
should be a bad guy there [ __ ] you
can't be a bad guy even if you try you
can't do it not in the genes in your
blood and only injure cojones it has to
be natural cuz if you try too hard you
end up looking like a baboon's ass how
do I know this it's from personal
experience I tried being a bad guy too
it does not work it's not me personally
all of my women friends think I'm a joke
which I cannot um it offends me for
example how are you gonna sleep over my
place and assume that I'm not gonna
trash it I'm a man [ __ ] I'm a mother
okay so you come say like I shut up
punch the baby seal in the mouth the
other day and I brought the babyGap
here's another thing ladies you can't
complain about the bad guys that you
choose you chose them you always come to
nice guy and then you ask oh my God why
did but cheat on me I don't get it
you know why it's because you went for
the bad ass that you thought was all
tattooed and mysterious for the
millionth time if he has a tattoo on his
chest to Muppet Babies trouble each
other out maybe he's not the man for you
just because he shows you up nice time
it doesn't mean you could change him he
don't have a job because
economy's bad oh no what a [ __ ] is
because he can't read you know what's a
good test
give him a word a secret pronounces all
the vowels and consonants in it hey baby
this thing says it's for a head-on chase
was it was a head-on check [ __ ] you
mean headache you know why he cheated on
your ass is because you went for a guy
that's - good luck in let me clarify
this for a second guys that predicate
who they are based on how they look are
pieces of [ __ ] they know that that
good-looking cuz that's all they got
what your answers need to do is find an
average looking guy with a great
personality our sorry answers would
never cheat on your fine ass is in your
mind you think you won because you're
like will you ain't never gonna cheat on
me you know they but not mine we went to
because we're like that's [ __ ] you and
Emily you know what this calls for guys
soon because a lot of you guys only
based attraction on looks and that's
your problem the end you don't finish
less because the whole world is all
against you it's because you're standing
up duh you can't hate some of them doing
the same [ __ ] that you do you don't say
hypocrite that's right that's a big word
come say Pat not fair boom babe hmm this
is awkward so if you think that the nice
guy is always gonna be around to stick
around the way for your sorry ass guess
what if anything like me i'ma tell your
boo gesture Peter well David I've
experienced the world in and I'm ready
for you now
fire what you want to hear a joke first
and knock knock who's there
vision not me
yeah I met her walking I need you more
than you need me I been searching for so
far my white tell me where can you be
baby I've been holding this thing for so
long
but I can't hold it in no more guess I
wasn't that strong bet you didn't know
I'm seeing about taking a dump tell me
why the taunting won't work held it in
for so long it hurts
plop plop drop that'll be in the
archives